well hello hi Greg Alva here the John
we're gonna check out a trailer for a
film that was really talked about at
Sundance and so it's a very serious
picture definitely it's dramatic it's a
moving art that's for sure it's called
Swiss Army this was army man Swiss Army
man yes it stars Paul day know who you
know from such great from dramatic films
like you know there will be blood and he
was a little miss sunshine and well
there's a slave looper and then it also
stars Daniel Radcliffe an actor who we
saw grow as up into a great actor in the
Harry Potter series some very dramatic
stuff and they're here to today to you
know with this movie that's a hardcore
drama for my understanding about farts
and stuff let's hit play John farting
farting corpse
Hey
in actually what did me but also like as
you have the helm
okay buddy you okay buddy
yeah
listen from structure
you're special he's special
progessive there's seven billion people
on the planet you might be lucky enough
to bump into the one person we want to
spend the rest of your life with
so this is the life I forgotten
my house
now
I thought it was just talked about cuz
of the plot well I mean people
supposedly walked out of sudden like
tons of people stormed out of the
screening at Sundance yeah because they
thought it was a silly movie about a
farting corpse like that's everyone
called it was Daniel Radcliffe's
farting corpse movie well now the whole
satire of the drama stuff at the
beginning of this video that we were
doing doesn't really count no I mean you
know it certainly got a silly just about
it but I don't think it's yeah it's not
like it doesn't know it feels more like
a sundance film yeah exactly it's like
you know an independent a quirky you
know life-affirming thing yeah I'm glad
I didn't focus too much on the farting
stuff if visuals look [ __ ] fantastic
you know I mean there's the locations
like that the island locations in the
forests and stuff like that it seems
like it's also kind of one of those like
man vs. nature roughen it movie yeah
like okay Paul
this is Dana or Dan oh I don't know I
think this is Dan but yeah I mean he's
obviously gonna have like the dramatic
role a more you know more energy more
emotional but honestly I looks like he's
doing a really good job as always Daniel
Radcliffe is the performance I'm really
interested in seeing yeah yeah yeah well
cuz Paul Danna at this point you're like
I know he's going to give a really good
like strange perform yeah you know you'd
always count any ad in Radcliff is like
not only this is a different kind of
movie for him but this is also like his
character seems to have very heavy
restrictions and I am that always makes
you know it's always interesting to see
an actor work with that and see what
they can bring to it yeah because this
is that's a role that could easily be
you know like boring in a lot of ways
that he's doing in a way just from what
I've seen from the trailer that actually
looks really cool if all goes well it
seems like you have to find that
balanced area between like stiff and
lifeless but with just the right amount
of emotion to make that out of the
motifs place so this could be really
impressive coming from him I think Paul
and Dan I was a hallucination I don't
think that's real I don't buy it
probably uh yeah I that's honestly my
theory
I think he's hallucinosis airily be like
that's gonna happen but I would not know
surprised if it was like he did it all
himself but he had this corpse with him
and he felt less lonely this is it a
love story Harley was a lovestruck it
per say it's just like I think he finds
like his greatest friend or something
like that you know like that bro man
yeah it's still a love story acted by
Judd Apatow yeah Paul Rose supposed to
be the Carson hog right I'm a beard yeah
that's good they'll have a James Franco
cameo and yeah his dick you know Selena
I like all this stuff where he's like
using the corpse to his advantage
you know I mean it was the thing we're
just like shoving that something down
his throat that that would know they
made like a grappling hook he like
shoved into her he must have like
squashed his stomach so it shot up into
the tree oh so it is like it seems like
as whimsical and kind of kind of goofy
and kooky that's what I'm wondering
about the tone is like maybe this was
too goofy for people yeah because these
directors come from like Adult Swim
material you know yeah yeah yeah this
was not at all what I was expecting but
it looks kind of delightful in a weird
way
yeah this almost seems like the thing
where it's like okay like we make some
fun some fun and subversive jet on Adult
Swim but let's do like a film like yeah
it's still funny but it's a film you
know it's definitely unique it's
definitely something that you know what
would be at Sundance it's not sure looks
like it's not something you know Warner
Brothers Studio you're scared it's so
weird like because you know any anything
with like you know silly corpse like
that almost the only way that would work
on a broad scale is if you made it like
a kids movie yeah like an animated movie
I really hope there's not that much
farting stuff I hate fart jokes I do too
but I almost feel like there'll be
something kind of alarming about it yeah
it might be charming in like a little
boy kind of way but also I think at
least one of those little moments they
were using them for some reason yeah
exactly think he led them on fire like
blast no tree
yo come home enter hey beauty hello
all right yeah well yeah I mean I guess
I'll watch it you know I don't know if
I'm gonna like I'm dying to see it but
if you know you invite me I'll probably
go I mean I'm definitely just because
this doesn't look like anything else and
because of all the mixed responses I'm
like and now I have to check it out well
guys yeah that's it for today's video
um listen if you're new to this channel
you can subscribe today and get rejected
yeah yeah hashtag and John over here me
has reasons to Jerry no and dank ass
Stubbs
on this channel yeah you check those out
you know dank ass thugs podcast if you
like his voice the reasons Jerry's all
the videos he does here where his face
appears in front of the camera and
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
links in description box and there's
probably an annotation watch more
trailer reviews so go check that out and
you can check out our channel page where
we feature a lot morning other sketches
on there some vlogs some unboxing videos
you know movie reviews we're a great
channel and we have a lot of love and I
just want to spread positivity for all
the people out there this is great you
should also use this as like your demo
reel for voice-over work it's really
soothing just there feel verse you got
to get better me your jokes got to get
better I am working on where I work how
many just not as strong as I was going
for sincerity and I was setting you up
there I say something funny
based off what I was doing and that's
what you came up with i demo reel yeah
it sounded like you're trying to be like
very soothing
just cut the camera no I'll come up with
a better jokes Oh give me one more line
alright um obese women deserve love - so
go to the description box and donate -
obese woman and it's like tinder but for
obese people how much have you donated
Ryan right I mean Greg ah